[Music]
[Music]
i love the scenes
between lisey and her sisters because
i tried to capture some of that sibling
rivalry dynamic
to me it's funny and it's touching
that the way we are as children with our
brothers and sisters
kind of lasts into adulthood
julianne jennifer and joan catch that
feeling of real sisterhood
to me those are those are my favorite
scenes
[Music]
something that is so well constructed by
stephen is these three sisters
how lizzy darla and amanda
they are so different from each other
how they love and
protect each other the core close
relationship of the sisters is pretty
central to the whole piece they have a
quirky
funny combative style between them like
all families i think they understand
each other and as
the episodes go on they really become
more and more united
as a team in their efforts to protect
lisey
[Music]
lisi loves her sisters very much and
when her sister needs help
she starts to remember things that
happen to her and starts to realize that
there's a way that she can
help her sister
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
you